学校の帰りにスーパーに行ったらね？
目を、疑うものが売ってました。
こちらです。これーは凄い
イルカの切り身でございます。岩手県産。
まさかのイルカですよ
ちょっとねぇ、目を疑うものがﾁｮｯﾄ売ってたんでねぇ、ちょっと買っちゃいました、イルカ
折角ね？キッチンも綺麗にやったんで、たまにはね？こう、今日の夜ご飯でイルカ。
ヤバくないですか？でも、こんなんだぜ
も、血だらけじゃん、何があった？
こういうとこ、イルカの皮膚だよ、多分。
あ、臭くね？
なんか臭いぞ。生、血、血の臭いがする。
魚はそんなもんか。
と言う訳で、早速料理してみましょう
はい、では早速作っていきまっしょい
まずねぇ、俺はねぇ・・・料理しないんすよ
なんで取りあえず、フライパンを温めてます。
フライパンを温めてぇ
れこ大丈夫？このまま食えんの？
でもすごいぜ。
あ～これがあのかわいいクジラだと思うと俺は心が痛いよ。
けどな？人は、食べないと生きれないんだよ。
わ～ これクジラの皮膚かなぁ
これ多分クジラの皮膚だもん、皮膚。
あー、もう心が痛い。
ダメだ、そんな事言ってたら死んじゃう
取りあえず、フライパンに、油をまきましょう
油が無いかもしんないですね
あ、有った、あった
こうね？ｵｯｹ、ｵｯｹ
ま、イルカはさぁ、魚じゃないしね、哺乳類だし、だからね魚じゃないんだよ、焼き肉みたい感覚で良いと思うんだよ
水洗いしなくていいかな？
え？どうなんだろう？何も分んない
水洗いした方が良いの？  どうなんだろう
大丈夫だよ多分、こう、熱であぶればこう、多分なんか食えそうだから
取りあえず、この黒いのと、
ちょっと血だらけのと、
皮膚付いてるので
多分この三種類なんですよ、取りあえずこれだけ作りましょう
ﾔﾊﾞﾔﾊﾞﾔﾊﾞい。ｱﾚが無い、あれが無いクルクルするのが無い
くそー、クルクルするのが無い。
あーごめんなさい。わー
あ、ヤバい、落ちた落ちた、、、熱い！あつ
ちょ、まって、やべーやべー、やべーやべーやべやべ
味付け、味付味付けしなきゃ
黄金のタレ行きましょう
あ！　塩掛けてない
これ、奥まで火通ってるとかどうやったら解るんだろうね
よし、じゃ取りあえず完成でございます。
ごめんなさい、クジラさん
心が痛みます
いや、そんなことダメだ。
クジラだけをかこう、わいがっちゃダメだ。
平等に扱おう、ね？
なんかこれもう大丈夫だよね
なんかすごい、血が付いてたからさぁ
先ずは黒いのから食べてみます。
頂きます。クジラさんごめんなさい。
いただきます
固い
んんん、あ！レバーの味だ、レバーの味がする
こっちもいただます
あ！こっちは柔らかい
レバー・・・の、・・・ちょっと、劣化番みたいな感じです
次はこの、皮膚付きの所食べてみます。頂きます。
コリコリして、軟骨みたいですね。
あ、でも何かイルカの味がする。
わ！なんか、ごめんなさい
なんか生々しい、ごめんなさいイルカさん
ごちそうさまでした
食べれるんですけど、なんかレバー的な味でした。
なんか、いい経験が出来たと思います。
これを人生の糧にして今後の人生も頑張って行きたいと思います。
じゃあな！